Hello everyone and welcome to day one of the Grantchester in Paris, it's the rapid event first
We're gonna have three days of rapid and then two days of blitz in the rapid event
the time control is 25 minutes for all moves and for every move starting from move 1 we have a 10 second delay and then
after three days of rapid we have two days of blitz like we said and then you will have
18 rounds of blitz with 5 minutes plus 3 seconds delay
So that's about the time control here. We have a wonderful game from round three young shift of do that versus Alexander agree. Shook
Really an insane game, but before we checked it out. We do have one nice photo
I want you to see courtesy of Leonard, Otis
Official photographer of the Grantchester and this really raises the bar in chess photography this I hope I hope you're ready for it
Here it is
Shocker Mahmoud Arif and Maxine washer, I grew up enjoying a nice swing there
You can see there are they're both very happy and regardless of how they play here in Paris you with this attitude
They are already winners
So there you have it. I do. Hope you enjoyed that in the description below as usual
You can check out some of her land. It's not her work. I will put on into his Twitter and Instagram
profile in the description below
So feel free to check out his other work now getting back to the game Duda opens with the white pieces
And he plays f3 we have D 5 by Gary shook
C4 and now d4 just grabbing more space in the center and we have B 4 by white
Why does the same and now controls a lot of squares on the Queen side?
With f6 by black. This is the main line
Preparing to push a 5 very rare that you will have an f6 in the opening
III and now he 5s plans and now white pushes c5, so this is all
Very nice preparation with a5 challenging the flank here
And Queen to a4 check and here you can choose if you want to block with the bishop
You want to block with the Queen you could also block with the night?
But that's a very rarely played
So you play best for blocks, then you can even play something like b5
But here we have Queen blocks and here do the plays Bishop to b5
Now of course attacking the Queen so c6 you have to play this Bishop back to c4 and now tonight's to a6
to capture on b4 and here Duda goes
He captures on d4
Grisha pushes the pawn with E for challenging the night and now just b5 challenging the night here on a six
with ninth to b4 and now a3 challenging the night once again, so here we have a trade ich atrás on f3
We have a character some before and now Queen captures on d4
So, what do you play here?
D3. This is the the way this line is played and how you will allow 25 check and a capture on g2
So this is all home preparation from Duda Queen e5 check with Bishop to e3 and now pawn captures on g2
Threatening to win the rook rook to g1. And this is where the game really begins because all of this has been played before
There is one game. I played in 2013 2014
It was played in the tournament over over New Year in Denmark Team Championship
Tiger Hill our person versus Johnny Hector played Queen captures on h2 here
And of course a white one a very nice game now white played a bit differently
But to probably do that prepare the the the correct line here after Queen captures on h2
Yes
You are threatening to capture the rook
But here white just ignores you white will just play King dead be to allow you to capture the rook and after Queen captures here
B captures and c6 not threatening to capture here with Czech grab another Queen and after black
well prevents this King to D it now you play Knight to c3 you threaten the Queen and
After Queen to h2 preparing to Queen the pawn
Now you play Knight to d5 with a terrible threat and here basically
Whatever black plays black will lose if you just play pawn to g1 Queen
You can just play rook captures on g1
Just to get in the Queen's the defense of the c7 square eliminated and after Queen captures
You can just play C 7 mate. This is just insane knife covers e7 the Queen covers this diagonal
This is just beautiful. And of course the knight guards the pawn here
so it is not possible to capture the pawn here and
Grisham did not know this agree. She had to calculate a lot here because Duda didn't waste any time getting to this position
he just without all of the mousse and
Grease you've spent a lot a lot of time and since you only have 25 minutes
You don't really get to spend all that much time. So we should play Knight to e7. He said, okay
I'm not touching that pawn. I mean if you play that all the way here and you're allowing it probably angry shook
Thought he doesn't even need to calculate it to know it's bad for him, but you can just trust your opponent
I mean you don't get to be
2027 in the 50 plus a grandmaster by trusting your opponents about okay here Duda also
Doesn't doesn't bother himself with the dg2 pawn
He just continues nice the d2 continues developing and again here you can capture on h2
But now okay Knight f3 guards the rook kicks away the Queen Queen age 5 and now Knights the d4 puts more pressure here
So you don't really want to do this, especially if you're running into preparation like Greece should be doing here
so after a 92 with Bishop to d7 by Greece shop, and now B captures on a5
And here Knights the d5 back Bishop Knight to F
I would have been a little bit better because it prevents a doulas idea here Duda goes D for
Attack the Queen if the knight was here. So you would be able to just capture the d4 pawn
But okay and then do that would play something else
Queen captures on h2
Now you have to play it
As you have to move the Queen either way and the white doesn't really have a good way to punish you
so why not Knight f3 defense rook attacks the Queen Queen to h5, and now even a 6
Here do this plan is to just capture on b7
give up the Queen and you don't really give up the Queen since you're gonna get another one and then you're gonna
Recapture the rook. So what do you do here question is can Greece you capture the night
Not really if you capture the night you get a capture some b7
Like we said that this doesn't do anything you just grab another Queen and then we capture the rook
so probably Ruby 8 and then you play B captures on c6 and now well Knight captures only 3 you can play this but then
c7 I think again you try to give up the Queen when I have two connected passed points on the seventh rank a black is
Dead lost here
For example Queen captures on b7 you can buy something like that
But it just captures on b8 with Czech Queen captures. And now Queen the a8 white is
With with the two connected response is in much better position. Check King b2
Now you have to trade here and after you move the King now even d5
Threatening v6 mate as the bishop covers over all of the squares here and the rook cover squares here
so
White can't even play in such a great style and whatever black plays now you capture the night and now you're just well better here
Bishop to e7 by Grichuk not caring about the knight on f3 and now Duda continues with his plan a captors n b7
Rook captures an a4 rook captures an a4 and now Grisha castles and here we have rook to e8
Just hoping to grab that rook and promote this pawn into a queen. So what could you play here?
Well, probably best was C capture some b5, but then you get rook captures on f8
Bishop captures on f8 you get another Queen into the game and then B captures on c4 you grab another Bishop and now it's
Hard to play this I mean, you know black would win this game. There's not all that much you can do here
To see the past t1 is very strong
you'd probably have to go back defend the knight on f3 and then it's just gonna be a terrible game for white so
Angry shook doesn't go with that idea, which was probably the the best way to go
He goes rook to e8, but okay. He wants the Queen to be able to recapture
So a white doesn't have a defender of the BH square when he wants to grab another Queen
With King to be two and now three shook again
Probably g5 and then after rook captures and g2 King g7
Just getting the kick out of the back crank, but still it's a tough position for Bishop
he's very long one time and well, he's uh
Hey, you you still feel that you ran into preparation and you have to you know, create something
But here instead of that degree, she played into f8, which does not work
So feel free to pause the video here and try to figure out why it doesn't work
Well, I'll give you a couple of seconds
For those of you who were able to do it
Congratulations, you have just found a brilliant line. And for those of you who just want to enjoy the show, you have to find
For but not now first
First you capture the rook and then if Bishop captures then you just get a queen in two games
Not really something you want to do Queen here and then after Queen captures here
And now you go Queen g3 Queen captures F captures and after captures captures
You will get C capture Sun be five but now Bishop to d5 and here it's a bishop and rook against two bishops
So while the bishop pair is very nice. The bishop in group will be will be stronger
For example f5 you're gonna capture on g2 soon
You're gonna get rid of this one end at the end of the day. You have to connected pass pawns, so not happening
So a grecian of course went with Queen captures on e8
And now comes Bishop captures on d5 removing the defender of DF Foursquare
And now it's all over there's no defense against this if you capture the pawn Bishop f4 regards the queening square
You're just gonna Queen that pawn
This is why I said if you found Bishop therefore, then you easily found rook captures and Bishop captures on d5
so we're just played rush up to d8 here, but it's
The same doesn't really work
the idea is I mean there is a trick now if
Duda promotes the Queen then you get better pay five check and then you just pick up the Queen black black wins the game
Ah, but dude, of course is not tricked easily. He just played the Bishop to f4 controls the BH square
We have the short a5 check by Grisha, but King to d1 and it was in this position
That Alexander really should resign the game as there is nothing more to do here
Whatever you play next move you get a queen enter game and it's all over see captures b8 Queen and white is just up
too much material Queen captures Bishop captures and as you can see
Black has two bishops and White has two bishops, but also a knight and the rook which is very nice
After this came to be one angry to resign the game and brilliant victory forest of Duda, I will not mention
The standings as our I'm planning to show another game tomorrow morning. So we're gonna check out the standings then
So really an impressive game I do. Hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Co Co Co Co donal hughes, Jimmy Hernandez. Borislav Milano H and Clark Archer for conversion to my channel
Thank you a lot to really appreciate it and relations. Mr. Clark Archer who decided to return to competitive chess at the age of 49?
So congratulations on your decision sir, and you know, don't forget to brush up on that endgame
So I really really hope you enjoyed it and for the end of this video
Maybe check out this nice photo again and just look at those two. That's
That's looks like a lot of fun
Sir, as usual you can check to my previous videos your thing call for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the well the short coverage of the
Grantchester in Paris, continuing the capablanca saga and as usual checking up on your suggestions. Thank you
All I will see you soon and have an excellent rest of your Saturday